good afternoon welcome to the world
leaders forum at Columbia University I'm
John Coates with Dean of the London
School of International and public
affairs and interim provost of the
University from this vantage point the
value of the wave leaders forum to our
academic community looms large indeed
though I think virtually anyone who has
spent time at Columbia in recent years
appreciates the energy and excitement
generated by these events this is after
all the experience that would be
difficult if not an experience that
would be difficult if not impossible to
duplicate in any other city or at any
other university in the world the
animating principle of the world leaders
forum is the belief that the world's
most pressing problems will be solved
only through informed dialogue critical
scholarship and the free exchange of
ideas this fall's world leaders forum
began yesterday with a fascinating panel
discussion about the prevention and
treatment of non communicable diseases
in developing countries diseases such as
cancer diabetes heart disease and
chronic respiratory disease at the UN
General Assembly this week a
ministerial-level meeting is taking up
that very issue so we're off to a good
start in a moment we will be hearing
from a defective yayaya the president of
the republic of kosovo following her
talk president Jahjaga will participate
in a question-and-answer session
moderated by Professor John Misco
associate director of Columbia's
Harriman Institute I would also like to
acknowledge today the presence of Omni
SAP you the ambassador first sorry a
first ambassador of the Republic of
Kosovo who is also with us here this
evening
where are you master there
busting and yoga is the first head of
state to address this year's world
leaders forum she is one of a growing
number of female presidents and prime
ministers though it is still
disappointingly still disappointingly
small-group
it has increased by our count from 13 in
2007 to 22 days at sea would permit me
to say that her personal achievement
being elected to the presidency this
past April is all the more remarkable
given that Kosovo is the youngest
democracy in the world
president Jahjaga welcome to Colombia it
is no accident that president yoga has
assumed the mantle of leadership at this
moment in Kosovo's history her training
and experience in law enforcement and
criminal justice mirror the present
needs of the nation she has studied
these subjects at the University of
Christina and also abroad in England
Germany and at the FBI Academy here in
the United States in winning election
she earned the support of Kosovars
across the political spectrum who
recognized her personal integrity and
embraced her dedication to the rule of
law there are without question many
urgent matters on Kosovo's national
agenda yet the most profound may be to
create the transparency the
accountability and the civic
institutions that serve as the bulwarks
of democracy and the enemies of
corruption as has been the case for
virtually every nation enduring the
trauma and chaos of war and ethnic
strife the task of rebuilding civil
society marks the path forward for
Kosovo it will be essential in the
nation's quest for broader international
recognition sir Kosovo is a country
facing great challenges and at the
threshold of historic advances we are
watching events in Kosovo with
anticipation and hope please join me in
welcoming to the world leaders forum the
president of the Republic of Kosovo
Atifete Jahjaga Madam President
thank you very much
dear mr. Dean thank you for such as
thorough presentation of me and Kosovo
in general I'm really pleased to be here
today in between you and I will try to
elaborate a little bit from the my
approach from my way of seeing the
Kosovo situation in general where we
have been where we are here today and
where Kosovo is moving ahead and what is
the road ahead for Kosovo I am a firm
believer in the importance of the free
and the open debate and I welcome the
opportunity that the world leaders forum
and the Herman Institute have given me
to talk about my country in nearly 12
years ago Kosovo was targeted for ethnic
cleansing by the Serbian regime NATO
intervened to protect the civilians this
home Italian intervention became the
precedent for the development of the
norm of responsibility to protect or
intervention in defense of the victims
of man's killing and gross violation of
human rights by their state it is in the
line of thinking that led NATO to
intervene again recently in Libya and
this is why the experience of Kosovo
crisis relevance for the world and
future engagement in state building
efforts in mid-1999 we inherited a
country destroyed thousands of civilians
deaths
and the legacy of ethnic assault
hostilities recovery was not an easy it
took a lot of Health and a great deal of
the patients the emergency democracies
have much to learn from our experience
but first let me share with you my own
experience I have join it as a graduated
lawyer Kosovo police organization in
2000 an institution were building from
the ground you may ask me now what has
made a special for me to joining at that
time in the newly established country a
totally new established a police
organization and I would be saying to
you that my father was born in the jail
because my family opposed of the
community communist regime and was
prosecuted by its repressive police
force which was a tool of the state
against the people it was a tool of the
repression exclusive violent and corrupt
I grew up at the highest of the police
repression and I wanted a different
police fair lawful and truthfully over
the years Kosovo's police became just
that and Microsoft of Kosovo I
envisioned multi-ethnic and inclusive
effective and professional uncorrupt
and transparent that many of you would
like to see and you are seeing in every
day in your own countries in Kosovo
police force through my hard work I
succeeded to the highest rank within our
police organization which was
I resigned with the rank of the general
Lieutenant Colonel when I was approached
to become a candidate as a conceptual
candidate of Kosovo president to help my
country avoid a political crisis I step
it up to this call I saw it is an
opportunity to be an unifying president
that enjoys the support of the main
political parties and the communities
and as a Dean has presented for the very
first time in new Kosovo we have a
consensual candidate of the president
which has been elected for the very
first time in the Parliament of Kosovo
with 2/3 of the votes by the majority
and the minority within the Parliament
of Kosovo I committed myself to the call
of duty to serve my country and my
people in harmony with the ideas and the
values that I believed in and Here I am
today as the president of the Republic
of Kosovo my dear ladies and gentlemens
thanks to the efforts of Kosovo people
its institution and international
partners the Republic of Kosovo today is
a different country than used to be and
it's a different place today the
Republic of Kosovo is an independent
country the United States the leading
European countries 22 out of 27 and more
broadly a total of 82 so far have
recognized Kosovo as a state and we are
working towards gaining more recognition
to our statehood as one of the most
crucial elements is the recognitions of
portal independence of our country in
order to become a member of the European
Union united nation and all of
international and the regional
organization and insert the
Kosovo independence is reversible and we
have established ourself as a factor of
peace and the stability in the whole
balance in 2008 when we declared
independence we set clear clear
objectives in partnership with our
international partners and community to
build a democratic and inclusive country
and to protect minorities these
objectives are laid out in the
comprehensive status proposal known as
the Antasari plan and they are increased
but in our Constitution as well today I
can tell you that we are fulfilling that
commitment we have accomplished most of
those goals
Kosovo Constitution unlike others in
Balkans is based on civic and ideas of
the citizenship article clearly one in
our Constitution states a Republic of
Kosovo is a state of its citizens it
does not favor one ethnic group at the
expense of the others
on the contrary it includes strong
provisions to protect the minorities
what that is why our communities are
represented in the assembly through a
system of the guaranteed seats out of
hundred and twenty seats in the
parliament of Kosovo 20 of them are
reserved for the minority community that
makes less than 10% of the Kosovo
population and makes 10 percent of
overall community and minority groups
living in Kosovo serve representatives
hold the majority of the reserved seats
in addition to seeds they gain from
participation
in the election after 1999 after the end
of the war and the conflict in Kosovo
all of the government that has been
established are being compiled by the
majority and the minority since 1999
each of the government has one Deputy
Prime Minister belonging to the minority
group and over three ministers belonging
to the minority communities currently we
have one Serbian Prime Minister two
serbian ministers and one minister
belonging to the turkish moon it's a
moonie minority there is a strong
affirmative action program in place for
the civil service so that institution
such Kosovo police force reflect the
nature of the cost of of population that
has set up a good foundation for the
other institution to follow all of the
institutions in Kosovo of our government
are a multi-ethnic institutions to
ensure the legal protection of the
communities they can veto any amendment
to the Constitution and laws that may
impact their rights as a part of the
decentralization processes we have under
K taken we have built five new
functional municipalities run by named
minorities in various parts of Kosovo
which are equal in the exercises of
power with the rest of municipalities in
the country for example a Gretchen it's
a municipality which is not more than
six minutes drive from the capital city
of Pristina Serbs and their elected
representative around their municipal
affairs they also regulate their
cultural and religious affairs education
health care and appoint their local
police commanders as institutions of the
Republic of Kosovo we have also
recognized the legitimate right of
Serbia to show interest about the Serb
minority in Kosova
that is why we have established
provisions that regulate those links in
transplant manner through Kosovo's
institutions Kosovo citizens regardless
or their ethnicity and religion their
size or their percentage are now equal
by the laws of Kosovo
freedom of movement has been
accomplished anyone is free to travel
work and seek opportunities across
Kosovo in Kosovo the police has not
recorded any ethnically motivated crime
in the last seven years and this holds
true to the Kosovo Serbs more in general
Kosovo is working on strengthening its
rule of law addressing the corruption
and challenges of the economic
development as you said Mr cuss word I
have dedicated a part of my career
building Kosovo police force the most
trusted and respected institution in
Kosovo with the surveys done the most
respected in the region because I am
convinced that our prosperity relies on
security and so does our membership in
the European Union and a NATO that is
why we are updating all our legislation
to become more efficient in fight
against organised crime corruption and
trans-border crime like the law on the
confiscation of the assets that we hope
to complete by the end of this year
today just three hours ago before I came
here the Constitutional Court of Kosovo
has passed the constitutional opinion in
our Constitution about the immunity of
the delegates in the Parliament of
Kosovo this is one of the greatest
that any of the regional Balkan crunches
has been taken which guarantees that
they have no immunity over the crimes
that they have conducted
thank you
and this is not only a just a verbal
commitment on police and justice as well
as the international investigators who
work along us in Kosovo cooperate with
the regional countries to prosecute
transnational crime for all of the
professionals who had a little bit of
background on the crime would say that
the crime cannot be fight under the
isolation we have established ourselves
as the real reliable partner of the
American government in preventing
terrorism a several recent arrests that
are a result of our cooperation have
confirmed government officials who are
investigated for corruption cannot
remain in the office but allow me to
explain that organized crime and the
corruption are not a cost of a specific
problem they are a characteristics of
the countries in the period of the
transition to fight them we need
adjoining regional response and the only
reason answer to the joining regional
responses to golden words which I use it
is the cooperation and the collaboration
that is why at this crucial juncture to
be more efficient in organized crime and
other transnational threats Kosovo as a
state needs to be included in regional
and international organization that
focus on fighting this threat despite
the political disagreement I would very
much appreciate if one of you here would
be raising the hand and will be given me
an answer how they fight against
organized crime and trans-border crime
would be an effective if you are not a
member of international and the regional
organization against
fighting of the organized crime and the
corruption probably the answer will be
no the rule of law is the center of my
efforts to establish a stable state and
to contribute to the stability and the
security of the region it is from this
premise that I supported the joining
Kosovo police elix and the KFOR
operation in the northern part of Kosovo
that has been taken last week the action
is thought custom officials in two
border crossings between Kosovo and
Serbia that outside of the government
reach and became heavens of the
smuggling ladies and gentlemen I as a
president of the Republic of Kosovo
guarantee that we will remain focused on
this course because no matter what is
our standpoint where we come from or
what ethnic group we belong despite our
disagreement about how we got here we
can build up on our ambitions for the
future and that is the only way we want
kosovo and the whole region to be
prosperous democratic a member of the
European Union and the NATO as a main
grantee of the peace and stability in
the whole region of Balkans by being
active contributors and responders to
this processes it is in this
forward-looking spirit that we have
approached the dialogue with the Serbia
throw it we helped to find solution to
practical problems that would facilitate
the lives of our citizens despite our
political disagreements as a result of
these talks mediate mediated by the
European Union the citizens of the
Republic of Kosovo
can now travel with the Kosovo documents
and Kosovo issued license to Serbia
Kosovo education degree that were not
recognized are now accepted by Belgrade
many of you will be saying that how come
twelve years after this was not possible
in the scope of the freedom of movement
of all the people has not been hopefully
it will be after the region of the first
agreement of the process of the dialogue
the latest agreement on the custom stem
will enable the free and legal movement
of the god goods between both of the
countries as one of the golden rule of
the European Union and free trade and we
will look forward to the return of all
the documents that were seized by the
Serbia at the end of the war to be
returned to their home in Kosovo these
agreements are a means to normalize the
relation between our two countries the
dialogue is not one of the ways I say
it's one it's the best way for two
countries to normalize their
unstabilized their relation which they
have gone the other conflict and the war
they are pragmatic approach to some of
the real concerns they do not infringe
upon Kosovo serenity and they do not
contradict the Constitution's or the
laws of my country the society too has
made a progress to be clear our society
has not completely healed from the war
as I speak thousands of people across
Kosovo continue to be tormented about
the faith of about 1000 and 800 people
who are still missing
they have been Robert
of closer yet the society's desire to
move on and reconcile I reckon Silva is
inspiring in recent efforts by the civil
society to sign a petition for the
process of the regional reconciliation
in four former yugoslav units Kosovo met
the target support relative to the other
countries in the region touched by the
war an indication of the strong will of
Kosovo citizens to work towards the
future and leave the institutions to
deal with the prosecution of the crimes
of the past but my dear ladies and
gentlemans this does not mean that there
are no challenges or dangers that could
reserve reverse this process our
challenges today in Kosovo are threats
to the stability remembrance of the
unfinished businesses in three
municipalities in north Kosova radical
Serb elements which are connected to the
criminal groups and the networks have
rejected the Kosovo government they have
set a parallel security structures that
have obstructed and undermined our
efforts to reach out this part of the
community our position on this remains
very clear we will continue to work very
hard to integrate all of the communities
we will continue to extend to the Serb
community which has been held hostage by
these structures the rights and the
benefits that Serbs elsewhere in Kosovo
are enjoying we call upon Serbia to help
in dismantling this illegal security
struck
which days so far has been calling
parallel structures in the coming months
Kosovo institutions in partnership with
international actors will seek to engage
with this Serb community in the north in
order to best address their concerns we
want free and fair elections in northern
Kosovo to elect legitimate
representatives that will die by the
laws this will be normality in the north
from which all the citizens will be
benefiting what we want is achievable
but we cannot do it alone
we need to support the international
community including Serbia as foreseen
in the at asari plan that is the only
key of the success the full partnership
between all of the international
partners in order to find the best way
out of this but I will not agree to any
of the violation of the kosovo
sovereignty I firmly reject Kosovo
partition its international its internal
territorial rearrangement or exchange of
territories between the countries these
statements you have been heard before
but I would say this issue of the
exchange of the territory issue of the
internal rearrangements I would say
those are the ideas of the 19th century
people has to go away of those ideas
words over the territories has caused a
lot of consequences and the difficulties
that even today's date
most of the Balkan countries are
suffering with the consequences the
golden rule 3 of the European Union is
building the society with equal
opportunities for all of the people were
living within one or two borders I am
committed to this vision for my country
in the region multi-ethnic multicultural
a place of many faiths and traditions
where different cultures are a source of
enrichment where all the citizens live
with dignity and pride
my dear friends I would say that this is
the age of integration ideas that divide
people around country to this end and
before I end and leave up for more
questions or any of the comments you
might be raising here we need to find
ways to respect our divergence and built
upon our joint future I believe in our
ability to raise up all the differences
and find strength in drawing lessons
from the past and build the future but
not repeating the past I thank you for
your attention
and I welcome you to Kosovo the country
of young Europeans as we say so that you
can see yourself the past progress and
the positive process that has been taken
for only 12 years thank you
thank you madam president
my name is John mitts kill and I'm here
to moderate the discussion this evening
I would encourage particularly students
to take the opportunity to ask a
question not to make a political
manifesto but to ask a question and
before you speak please identify
yourself so we know who you are and
we'll take it from there so there are
microphones in the aisles please step up
hello I'm Ruben Saunders I'm a student
in Columbia College I'm just wondering
what you're doing to address Kosovo's
underlying economic problems can you
repeat it oh sorry I'm wondering what
you are doing to address Kosovo's
underlying economic problems I think is
the second time within about 30 minutes
that I have within this building
addressing this question economy it is
the point of the discussion and the
debate for all of the countries in the
world world for the moment but as I said
in the beginning Kosovo has been
undergoing for about over two decades
over the conflict with a totally
destroyed system which has by all means
has affected and has tackled all the
elements or the parts of the economy 12
years after with a continuous transition
and transformation we are now on the
process where at the moment we have
about 5 percent of the economy growth
which everybody would hear with you
would be green with me that's that's way
too low the government of Kosovo June of
this year has launched a long term
strategy development economic
development plan which has been
following with an action plan and for
the very first time after 12 years the
economy development plan was done in
Kosovo not solely by the institutions of
Kosovo but was done with international
community and international partners
resident in Kosovo which is mainly from
the European Union but I would say that
the Kosovo has a very favorable market
over 64% of the community they come from
the young generation as you are here
they are in between 20
and up to 35 there is a huge potential
between the capacities of these people
we have a very low tax rates which is
the lowest one in the euro not saying
into the Balkans and we have a very
strong banking system which would be
guaranteeing the international or the
foreign investment Kosovo is very much
open for the foreign investment this has
been incorporated or included here also
in our five-year strategy for economic
development but COSO is having some
difficulties with the regard of the
European Union
due to the trade relation and due to the
contractual relation with the European
Union due to the fact that the five
countries out of 27 has not recognized
the independence of the Kosovo so you
can imagine operating and trying to
build rebuild and have a very
sustainable and stable economy in
operating in the oscillation that we are
handling for the moment thank you madam
president
thank you hi I'm hungry two year I'm
from Columbia College and I'd like to
know what message do we have for ethnic
groups that are also struggling with
their own independence movements such as
the Basques the Chechens and the Kurds
the messages are numerous but they I
always say that there is no copy and
paste concept each of the country is
unique to its own specification although
something would be working out or would
be not working out the only difficulty
that Kosovo after the war back in 1999
which we had with international
community was the difficulty or the
temptation of imposing the copy and
paste processes from the other best
practices or from the other
scenarios in other countries of the
world that time the leadership of Kosovo
had a very strong send that the copy is
good but has to be adopted to the need
and the specification but I go back to
my two golden words which is the
cooperation and the collaboration and
the proper process of the dialogue if
there is a full commitment to those
three elements there is always a way out
thank you hi Elizabeth proj Columbia
College as a fellow opinion I was
wondering after everything so has gone
through it Serbia to the citizens of
Kosovo present the Serbian officials in
Parliament or they have they become to
live in harmony with one another if I
understand well your question as I said
the Kosovo government or the Kosovo
Parliament has it is not only that it's
been regulated with the participation of
all of the communities by our highest
regulating body which is the
Constitution of the Republic of Kosovo
but it's been followed with our other
legislation which regulates the rights
and the obligation towards the
minorities out of 220 seats in the
parliament of Kosovo over 20 over 20
seats are reserved only for the
minorities out of this 20 seats 10 of
them are reserved for the Serbian
community exclusively but we have not to
forget that only 8% of the population in
Kosovo it's composed of out of the
Serbian community so there is a
representation in the institutions of
Kosovo it's over 10% at the moment they
represented and they are free in the
decision-making from starting from the
local level of the new municipality all
the way to the central level or in the
government of the Kosovo yesterday that
we are speaking we have one Deputy Prime
Minister which is second in the line of
the government and we have three
ministers belonging to
minorities thank you good evening
jihad Nnamani Columbia Business School
my question is to follow up on the
economy economy question that was
earlier what do you think the role of
the infrastructure will be developments
of infrastructure will be in Kosovo
going forward especially after the
destruction that happened during the the
war and late 1990s and if that happens
where are the funds going to come from
to fund infrastructure developments in
Kosovo yes as I said in the beginning
that Kosovo was coming out on this new
era or this past 12 years as of a
totally ruin system including the
infrastructure right after the conflict
the majority of the concentration has
been established to rebuilding the roads
and the infrastructure which will kind
of stabilize and normalize the normal
life of the people so they would be
having open roads open streets to finish
and fulfill all of their requirement and
the services that they will need to do
it to do it back in 2001 and of 2001 we
have started with a process of the
privatization so calling for the first
two or three years being very open to
you we had some difficulty with the
process of the privatization because
there was not a very clear strategy by
the government that time that the money
taken by the and the investment coming
from the privatization to go back to the
proper investment within the country
development but two years after the
process of the privatization this
process has been drifted down and now we
have much more relaxing process of the
privatization mainly about the bigger
company or the largest companies but we
have also to
had to bear in mind that over 60% of the
international community investment has
been done in the infrastructure and
building of the country coming from the
European US institution in all over the
world thank you my name is Bob Sun I'm a
student at Columbia College you speak of
cooperating with the international
community but the international
community's late what is the nature
nature of Kosovo's current relations
with Russia back aggregate to this the
importance of the proper cooperation and
the cooperation Kosovo is an independent
country a country which has been
recognized by over 82 countries a
country which has its sovereignty and
the territorial integrity a country
which for the past 12 years has been a
great role model in the region for a
very good regional and cross regional
cooperation and the neighborhood
relation Kosovo had some difficulties
due to the stand of two or three
regional countries it's a Serbia and one
of them has already mentioned by your
side that the Kosovo has not became a
member of many of the European and
international organization that is not
an obstacle for Kosovo that is an
obstacle for the countries which are
already in those organization one of the
main intention and the main objectives
of the European Union and one of the
main requirements on moving on the
direction of the European Union is to
have a very good regional and cross
regional cooperation and strong
neighborhood relation so Kosovo has
shown to be very open and very
constructive only 12 years after the war
and I believe that those foundation
has to be built and I continuously seek
even the seeking comes also from the
audience that we you are here today that
the one of the ways of moving on the
direction of the tackling of the matters
which of the global importance is being
a member of all organized a regional and
international organization and not the
country to become a map to become an
obstacle of another country which we
have seen for this past 12 years thank
you my name is Abdullah
I'm from the college I was in Kosovo
several months ago and many of those I
talk to especially those the youth
between the ages of 18 and 26 complained
of a sort of corruption or even no
nepotism at the administrative and at
the governmental level even so I'm
wondering if that kind of corruption is
acknowledged in your office or if it's
combatted at all I think I trust also
with my entry marks about the commitment
of the government of Kosovo and my
personal commitment and my personal
legacy during my tenure as the president
of the country would be fight against
organized crime fight against corruption
and the transporter crime Kosovo
institutions have established a very
good foundation by creating a very
sustainable capacities within the police
organization and within the justice
element we have to not forget that the
Kosovo is also supported by the
international organization which is
called EULEX
it's European Union rule of law mission
that many of those crimes if we can save
has been a reserve competence starting
from 1999 beginning with UNMIK now with
the EU
but we are very much committed to help
the yulux to better fulfill its mission
mandate by slowly trying to pass the
competences of this nature of the crime
to the local authorities because only
the local authorities can know the best
way how to tackle we have set up a very
good legislation base for that as I said
which was has been followed here today
the Constitutional Court of Kosovo has
issued the decision even about the
immunity which is a great element on the
fight against organised crime and the
corruption but the elements of the
organised crime and the corruption are
not a solar problem of Kosovo I would
say that this is more a matter of the
perception if we just go by the
statistics and by the surveys that has
been done for the test years this is
drifting from one percentage to another
percentage but I don't want to justify
that or to hide them behind these
curtains but I would would try to
underline that there is a proof
commitment a huge commitment between the
institutions of Kosovo to better tackle
of those nature of the crimes which are
not tackling only the society within the
country but this is the disease of many
of the regional countries not saying
that many of the countries in the world
but the king of being successful on the
mission on the fight against organised
crime and the corruption is cooperation
and the original cooperation I come from
that profile being for about six years
exclusively linked on the fight against
organized crime and the corruption how
you can fight a crime and the corruption
where you have an organization which is
not a member of the Interpol Europol and
other regional organization criminals
are better
nice than professionals I think we need
to switch the places that we have to be
more committed how we closely we can
cooperate and not make it only isolated
case of Kosovo or isolated case of
Macedonia or Montenegro this is a
regional matters so has to be a full
commitment by the leadership in all over
the region to badly tackle those natures
thank you hello madam president hello
madam president I'm Lauren Murad school
of general studies here you mentioned in
your inaugural address that Kosovo's
path is to be a new member so my
question is simple in your opinion what
is the difference between an EU
membership and a privileged partnership
that makes you want to prefer being a
member these are two separated I did you
see the partnering for peace no new
membership and the privileged
partnership like the one that nobody has
for example definitely not only the goal
of Kosovo but this is the regional
concept and the regional approach and
this is the brussels view or the vision
about the enlargement of EU towards all
of the balkan countries Kosovo has done
a lot of progress
comparing with any of the regional
countries as regard of the reform and
the standards which had to be fulfilled
in order to become an EU member state
Kosovo is the only country in the region
and fortunately I have to say that has
not benefited out of the contractual
relation and the stabilization
Association processes the processes
which I consider are the engine of the
internal or the domestic reform
processes within the country this
processes are not necessary for the
country these processes are more
necessary for the European Union and for
the new concept in you has to have find
a model or the formula which is going to
fit not in the concept for all of the
country but is going to fit in
individual countries in order to meet
that path towards the euro-atlantic
integration thank you very much my name
is Jim nur from the Columbia Journalism
school from what I understand in in the
rural areas of Kosovo and Albania the
customary law of Canon it still sort of
serves as the primary rule of law in
these areas in these regions of these
countries and I was just wondering has
the cassavan government incorporated
some of these Canon laws into
constitutional law and if not do you
think that do you think that
constitutional law should incorporate
culture specific and you know
traditional laws into the law or should
it actually adhere to a universal rule
of law based on democracies around the
world
the Constitution of Kosovo as the
highest regulating body if I may
understand you correctly that you said
that the fight against organised crime
and corruption to be incorporated into
the Constitution no actually I was
asking if customary law like the commune
has been incorporated into
constitutional law in Kosovo and do you
think it should be
I think we passed the centrist my only
answer would be that we passed the
centuries and know by all means that
should not take place and should not be
the Danish president my name is my name
is Jacob Barack I'm from Columbia
College class of 15 and you mentioned
before the importance of foreign
investment in your infrastructure and
also the importance of Interpol and I'm
just wondering how Kosovo intends to
maintain its an autonomy in the face of
a large amount of foreign investment in
the future the politics of the economy
are drifting from one mode to another
mode and that depends also from the
internal politics of the country but the
our long-term development strategy for
the economy and the foreign investment
is something that we have foreseen for
the upcoming five years for our country
and I think I had this discussion just
before I came here that Kosovo is
sitting in the most important routes to
the east and the West small country of
only 14,000 square kilometers and about
two million population but is sitting in
the heart of the Europe in the corridors
of the East and the West
outsourcing is something that some of
the bigger countries should be looking
as a target and as a strategy for
expanding into that region thank you
hello my name is Laura I'm a student at
the School of International and public
affairs here at Columbia and I'm from
Argentina so my question is what is the
strategy
of the relationship between Kosovo and
Latin America the nature of this
relationship because I know many of the
countries in the region doesn't
recognize Kosovo yet my answer would be
that the relation would be starting from
here with your question and I would be
losing you towards the Latin America a
lot before Kosovo's recognition so we
can build up in this relation okay I'm
flattered thank you good evening my name
is Joshua Patel from the Columbia
College firstly I want to thank you for
speaking to all of us tonight
secondly what role if any does religion
play in politics or in the public
opinion of Kosovo thank you very much
and I did say in the beginning that the
Kosovo it's a very multi-ethnic
multicultural multi-religious country
and we are proud for our inter religious
tolerance Kosovo not only from today not
only from the decade back but for about
centuries back we have the Catholic
Muslim and the Orthodox living
side-by-side living together
respecting their cultural tradition
religions and their monuments but Kosovo
and cost of our people our European
people we belong to the European
civilization if we say it like that and
the values of the parliamentary
democracy building the state and
separating the state from the religion
has been one of the greatest values that
we have been inherited and we are
building for the continuous
years thank you hello of Madam President
my name is Julian Hernandez I'm a
student at Columbia Law School and you
had mentioned your commitment to
stopping trans-border crimes and from my
understanding human trafficking is a
very prevalent trans-border crime in the
area and I was wondering what specific
plans if any you had to combat that and
if your experience in the police
department was assisting you in any way
thank you and I have more to switch ammo
my head and give you a more of the
professional answer into that the
elements of the trans-border and
organized crime
are for kosovo especially in the regard
of the trafficking of the human beings
which for many of the country is one of
the main obstacle for some of the
country in the region which is Romania
and others they have a majority of the
problems with that Kosovo is more used
as the transit corridor for these levels
of the crime or the nature of the crimes
but Kosovo is the only country in the
region that has established the most
efficient legislation as regard on the
trafficking of the human beings there is
a law passed in the government of Kosovo
in the parliament back in 2007 for the
fight for the fight against organized
crime with a specific on the trafficking
of the human beings there is a National
Action Plan which has been developed and
is being renewed every year in the six
months basis
third is the separate the victim
advocacy and protection programs if I'm
correcting my English expression has
been established Kosovo has been used as
a good example from all of the regional
countries
Kim Joon and of June I was in the
conference as the panelist in Lithuania
where there were there was a discussion
about the ways of best ways of tackling
of the trafficking of the human beings
Kosovo was taken as one of the greatest
examples in the region with a link
between the legislation between the
police capacities and between the
justice capacities thank you madam
president
Thank You mr. president
I'm a student from School of
International and public affairs I have
two questions the first way you
mentioned that Kosovo is opened in
regard of the trading international
trading so I want to ask the question
about the status of the trading with
Siberia because it looks like it's not
so stable sometimes there is impact over
goods of rambling and another question
is you have give us the numbers about
the integration of the minority group in
the parliament and the governments and
departments so once you ask if there are
any plans to help appeal to the
community integration and you know to
heal their wounds created a battle wars
thank you very much and first I will go
back to once more to the proper
integration process and the steps ahead
that the Kosovo has and institutions of
Kosovo has been taken with the regard of
all of the communities doesn't matter or
they belong to the Serbian community to
the Bosnia to the Turkish gypsy to the
ashkali and other minorities there there
is a very good strategy in place issued
by the government of Kosovo for the
proper integration I don't want to
mention again the adversary plan which
mainly refers to the Serbian community
which has already shown its first result
with all of the units
politics in Kosovo despite three
municipalities in northern part of
Kosovo which I referred also in my entry
talks when I said that this the expanded
or the integration in these three
municipalities in the north has not has
been an obstacle for the institution of
Kosovo due to the operation of the
illegal structures in the northern part
of Kosovo mainly implemented by our
neighbor country of Serbia so this
people has to be left alone to have a
proper judgment where and how they see
their future their future is on and the
only answer to their future is within
the Antasari package which was done in
the full partnership between the
international community and the
government of Kosovo approved by the
Parliament of Kosovo the same model is
applying to all of the communities
though we have some difficulties at the
moment with few of the minority groups
due to the new approach or the new
processes that some of the European EU
member state countries has started to
return the refugees out of their
countries so the strategies immediately
has been established but we had a
difficulties of finding the proper
funding to properly facilitate the entry
integration process after their returns
but now since June time we have a very
good line of the reintegration as regard
of the trade and the market with Serbia
as you know many of you maybe have seen
from the latest development on the media
about the constitutional and the legal
right the decision which has been taken
from Kosovo institution to bring the
rule of law in the whole territory of
Kosovo mainly in three municipalities in
the north me as a president of the
country
I have to uphold the Constitution we
should not allow any of the area which
we can see as a gray area where the
organized crime and contraband could be
blooming that what was happening in two
three municipalities in the north as a
result of the process of the dialogue
after the cancellation of the free trade
agreement which was unilaterally one
side by Serbia was terminated back in
2008 where it has forbidden for the
Kosovo Goods to travel and to be passed
toward Serbia Republic of Kosovo after
the taking of the decision or the rich
in the agreement after the process of
the dialogue in the Brussels between
Republic of Kosovo and the Republic of
Serbia has started the implementation of
this agreement on the customs reached to
continue making Kosovo as one custom
zone and to make continued the rules the
role of the free trade and free
marketing as one of the main rules of
the European Union you will get a chance
to answer your I'm sorry to ask your
questions but not in this forum because
this part of our meeting is now coming
to a close we're going to invite
everybody to come to a reception just
behind the podium here and if you like
you can ask the president your question
then on everybody's behalf I would like
to thank you for a very stimulating
discussion a good lecture and we welcome
you back any time